go monkey what are you saying um what
state starts with the pencil
which states start with the pencil yeah
like the name oh I think I know this one
Pennsylvania
yeah with some good jokes you know
another joke
um what do you call Chico's a butt a
chick with a butt yeah
a chicken with the butt
a chicken head
chicken butt a chicken butt
but today is Father's day and we're
driving to Lake Mead and I'm really
excited because since we moved here I've
been wanting to go to Lake Mead but we
moved here during a drought so
everyone's like that's not as beautiful
like all the Vegas locals would say that
but as you guys know it's been raining
like crazy Across the Nation so water
levels have been replenished and I'm
like today is Father's day Mama asked me
what do you want to do and I was like I
want to go to Lake Mead rent a boat
drive around Cruise because I've been
seeing pictures of it and it looks
beautiful so that's where we're heading
to right now
why do fish need to live in salt water
because they're salty yeah
pepper water they sneeze that's a funny
one
another one yeah what's it called a dog
a dog that looks like a wolf
Amina
these are jokes anymore dude hey what's
going on that nose
all right
this part is so trippy because no one
really knows about Lake Mead but every
time you arrive at Lake Mead it's it's
big old body of water and I'm always
reminded
of how big Lake Mead is for some reason
like in my brain I feel like I can swim
across easily but it's actually pretty
huge on them it's massive and what's
trippy about it just that like it's in
randomly in Vegas that there's this big
old body of water
oh sleeping bag is usually a big desert
right yeah there's actually a ton of
stuff like Mount Charleston has a bunch
of like pine trees yeah it's not too far
away and then Lake Mead
is actually really really really big
ocean yeah it's like a little mini ocean
a little mini means it's so small it's a
big ocean yeah
every time I see a body of water it
makes me feel so happy and peaceful look
how blue it is
crazy bones
is that does it make you feel like that
Mama like I want to see in a body of
water yeah
yeah it's very soothing again
it kind of looks like
it looks like the legs are kind of green
really how do you know about those
colors because I've seen them before and
and oh yeah yeah and they're frog I
think there's frogs in there I know this
frogs you heard them
ecology things don't you are you gonna
go into the lake
no you go for Lego seconds okay I'll go
first
yeah what if I don't know
I'm gonna go third and she's gonna go
play it so this place is actually bigger
than I thought we're at the Lake Mead
Arena a bunch of people Park their boats
here
um I even saw like boat and RV and like
other toy like um one of those things
called jet ski storage kind of like down
the road over there
it's really hot oh it's really hot okay
thank you
but it's so cool that all these people
are bringing their dogs on
for these Adventures
like those little guys there too
so this is also the same place where uh
it's the same place where we would also
rent the boat I think usually to be
smart you wanna
book ahead of time
it's kind of like a spur of the moment
thing so fingers crossed that they have
some boats that we can rent and we can
cruise around the water does look very
refreshing
and I can't wait to jump in are you down
to jump in nope not at all nope
is it because it's not the ocean or the
temperature or what is it I
know okay
doesn't want to get wet do you think
Mama complains a lot or no
she does about about about what usually
about water yeah is there anything to do
with the temperature
what about you do you complain about the
cold
sometimes
[Music]
being offensive
what did you just say monkey you think
there's platypuses yeah they're Ducks
but you think
hey don't scare them don't scare them
platypuses are in Australia okay mister
no they're not in Las Vegas
where right there oh wow there's a lot
of fish
whoa whoa
that's a lucky
that's a lot of fish
bad news
no uh so they said that because the
winds are pretty high today there's no
rentals
but we could probably find the place we
could swim and stuff yeah sure
put your finger in there see what
happens
you wanted a suck on her finger
sorry whoa some of them are huge
there's some big old fishes over there
[Music]
no what is it oh me neither
I thought you were gonna teach me
something yeah
I recognize the car for the scales
Shark look how friendly these guys are
yeah
[Music]
they'll let you put them very nice
gotta go closer look
I'll help you
I thought you wanted because you know
what you're doing you're going like this
I want to pet them and you're like this
far away I want to pet them I want to
pick them
you gotta stick all the way in like that
don't worry
to do anything to hurt you I'm only
gonna throw you in 100
. oh my God
so we're at the uh Beach portion of it
and lesson learned and if you guys want
to come down come early because once you
come early you can actually park your
car on the beach
it's pretty freaking cool now I know
it's my first time out here like this
so we parked over here not too far but
you can probably set up camp and
barbecue
dude
is gone
around
like no
okay Mr white box is ready
you ready for the sun let me spray water
at you okay
here we go
ready move me up oh yeah move this way
ready here we go
oh
so even though I came under prepared
the setup is still decent
because I always got stuff in the back
of my truck shout out to the deck who
sent me the system so I always have like
range gear and all that and I always
pack one of these moving blankets
because they're very helpful one in
emergency because I'm traveling back and
forth from uh Vegas to LA all the time
in case it gets cold I get trapped in my
car I have a blanket but also if I have
to move things or if I need like a
little rug to set up for a little
campsite I always keep a chair
just in case just one chair so now mama
has a place to sit relax got this cool
truck backed up into the lake and we got
the little the little white guy right
there looking at shells I didn't think
it was gonna be that
Mia
did you find any seashells Mister yeah
you're playing a game what are you
playing
oh look at all these little seashells
right there
yeah
[Music]
Mama's all there over there can you get
to Mama
hey you're swimming
uni
Mia
you little silver shark hey good job Mia
Yay good job
good job
[Music]
so that was a really CUNY fun adventure
we just packed up real quick just swam
for a quick little hour
just making sure guys ever want to come
looks like this super blue water and
next time we're gonna bring Gio's
brother to fam for sure it will come
early morning set up a canopy bring a
grill have a good old time music
everything just hang out the whole day
a lot of fun huh
we all love the water it seems like Mia
I'm so stoked yeah I thought she loves
to swim so much look at her they get her
in the back like a little wet first you
have a good time
so other than today being Father's Day
pretty typical Sunday
we like to wrap things up
do the laundry
why
no it's awesome I mean there's nothing
wrong with regular days I love every
single day that I have with you
yeah I love every single day every day
is a birthday every day is a Father's
day every day is Christmas
yeah I love it
so yeah it's really typical
um like meal prepping I'm actually going
back to LA later this week so I just
need to make enough chicken for the meal
that I just had and then for a couple
other meals
wash all the dishes
we were gonna give me a bath but she was
in a lake and she looks pretty clean and
I think that
yeah she brushed her and I think the
lake water reactivated the uh shampoo so
she actually smells really really good
we put the young man
to sleep
so he's sleeping in there
but yeah thank you guys for
um sharing this lovely Father's Day with
me
ASAP
we got the wife folding we got the
husband not doing per usual what
are you talking about I'm doing
everything
just about to
yeah so yeah we're um
yeah thank you for sharing this cute
little Father's Day with me it was short
it was a nice little event it was cool
because uh I wanted to ride a boat
but now I know I should call because the
wind conditions prevent you from biting
a boat but you also had a really CUNY
time swimming and watching medicine
which you've never seen or some that
makes me so happy that she loves water
so much because once we built the pool
she's probably gonna be in there and
it's gonna be a great great time because
I love it when dogs get in the Water by
themselves
and that's always my favorite so happy
Father's Day to all the fathers I watch
and we'll see you guys next time